when mankind decided to become what we
call civilized a good example of that
that everyone can relate to is when the
wild wild west was settled
it was anarchy it was chaos whoever
could draw a gun the fastest ruled the
street and would take whatever you had
that you thought was yours and take it
for themselves the strongest biggest
meanest most violent were the only ones
that prospered then Wyatt Earp comes to
town and says no we're going to remember
the phrase clean this town up and
instead of chaos order ensued and then
is the only time that Commerce can occur
you know what I'm talking about
yeah the economy boomed when Wyatt Earp
and of course we love I love the movie
tombstone they come in they clean up and
all of a sudden families want to move in
businesses want to build and expand and
now order allows for commerce and life
to take place there's no question about
it chaos is not a place that business
people go no they flee and the reason
this business requires a predictable
environment you you cannot say I'm gonna
save up thirty thousand dollars over the
next five years to open a hardware store
and then someone come kick the door in
and take all my stuff and everybody
stand around and go that's okay yeah and
so the net result is that where commerce
can a commerce can occur people can
build lives only in predictable
environments and that we you know we
that the phrase has been co-opted but
it's order versus chaos and it's law
versus lawlessness thus law and order
now law and order sounds like some big
mean guy in a military suit or something
to some people but it just means that
there's a rule of law where people
aren't stealing other people's stuff
destroying other people's stuff killing
other people raping other people without
anybody doing anything about it
yeah there's a rule of law and there's
and so chaos has pushed out order come
commerce can occur and so we're seeing
that with riots not peaceful protests
but we're seeing that with riots and
we're seeing that with politicians
completely out of control
making up every day as they go kovat
regulations and basing them on
questionable science these same medical
people who six months ago apparently
they don't do math in med school yeah
it's something that doesn't come up much
and so what you've got is you've got
some areas of the country that where
we've had a pretty vanilla I mean pretty
generically predictable environment that
you could go into any city and do
business now you can't so I'm sad to
announce that we are canceling smart
conference in Minneapolis yeah this fall
yeah we can't go yeah makes no sense for
us to go well it's I mean it's downtown
yeah the Target Center in the middle of
Minneapolis the police are defunded i we
cannot put our the people that we love
that we're trying to help at-risk
because I don't I don't know what I'm
gonna walk into there it's scary yeah
I'm scared to go yeah and so I'm not
gonna go I'm scared to do a thing down
there can you imagine if we had a ramsey
thing and then there was some big
violent thing and somebody got killed or
several people got killed or hurt or
maimed or some child got harmed and it
was because i was there doing a thing
that would ruin my life you know
emotionally I couldn't take it yeah
because we were there to help yeah and
so because it's an unpredictable
environment I can't go I can't go to the
City of Seattle no you can't open a
business in Seattle right now because
you don't know what's going to occur and
that's not a statement of the people
that are angry with that their anger
isn't valid you you there's some lots of
reasons that are valid to be angry but
it's it's a statement of what has
occurred as a result of that you've got
leaders and there's no law and there's
no order and so you don't have a
predictable environment commerce cannot
occur it's like you know Mike migraine
kids were over the other night and one
of them in the playroom took a block and
hit the other one in the head you know
it's what they always do right and they
come out screaming you either thought
the work and having a fit angry and hot
and hurt right angry and hurt just
melting down four years old right well
you know so what has to happen well papa
dave has to say well justice is going to
occur here I will take care of the
offending block thrower but you that are
angry and hurt while you have a valid
reason you got chunked in the head you
have a valid reason for being angry and
hurt you're not gonna burn the living
room down mm-hm
and you're not gonna break Mimi's China
because I will bust your little butt
okay so in the in the midst of your
valid anger your misbehavior is not
going to destroy my home I don't know
where I get these ideas I think they're
old fashioned and I'm probably going oh
there's a canceled culture thing right
so I'm probably gonna get cancelled now
because I said these things out loud
well cancel my butt
have at it we're good with that have at
it well you know yours I am NOT
invalidating the reasons for the anger
are not right valid I am saying got
chunked in the head with a block you
have a right to be angry huh a little
little four-year-old but then you cannot
melt down and destroy my house as a
result because it's my home I own it
I've worked hard for me means China and
besides that if I don't bust your butt
made me a bust your butt for breaking
her China I'll just tell you that she'll
light you up and so there's gonna be
order there's gonna be law and there's
gonna be justice and there's gonna be
kindness and there's gonna be love and
that can only occur in a situation where
there's order it's exactly right we love
Minneapolis it's we've been there
wondering anytime wonderful time in my
six years here I don't know of a warmer
more electric crowd hopefully we'll be
back but the reality is this is the
right decision there's just too much
uncertainty because of a lack of
authority you know the living room
illustration is huge first thing you did
was you calmed everything down let's get
to the facts who's wrong all right let's
punish the grandchild to hit the other
one in the head but then we're gonna
make sure that we go okay it was good go
our separate rays separate ways we're
gonna punish you we need to punish we're
gonna heal and there's gonna be some
order if you're not involved
that living room who knows what happens
now they're all beating up on each other
and we've got our top down right and so
that's unfortunately what situation
we're facing as the City Council voted
12 oh 12 0 to defund now it hasn't
happened yet that's got to pass with the
citizens of Minneapolis and I'm anxious
to see how that goes but the reality is
we can't be there because we would be
endangering the very people that we love
to serve and it's really sad and on top
of that with the event we do a
celebratory right which would be
tone-deaf in the middle of this to go in
there let's all think positive right you
know you can be what you want to be
that's about a dumb but message in the
middle of that you know I'm not going to
do that yeah and so which is a true
message but it's tone-deaf you know yeah
there's a lot of very serious things
there that that need this message but we
can't be there so I'm sorry guys but
those of you that have tickets will be
refunding your tickets you'll be getting
an email immediately and I will let you
have your money back as soon as we can
get the your orders processed it'll
probably take a month or so to get all
those process but we'll get an email out
to you this week but that's the case and
some of these cities I you know I'm just
not going to your city until your city
can behave and it's not punishment it's
I'm scared
I'm afraid of the way your politicians
are going to act or whatever